eric was this deliberate is this some
mind games going on
so i was wearing a different color
hoodie
and then i saw you wearing the yellow
hoodie and i had to
i just had to match for the color
scheming and the color meaning
i wanted to grow facial hair but i only
had like
a few minutes after i saw your face so
i tried but uh didn't grow quickly
enough
i wanted to grow facial hair
did i miss a memo by the way because
everyone's wearing like yellow
i missed the memo too but apparently i
was lucky
okay i'll be right back oh boy
does socarro own anything yellow oh he
does have some
yellow hands oh that is yellow
i don't think i've ever seen hakara wear
is just like full yellow
yeah no i've never seen that's not my
color
it's not your color but thank you thank
you for
blending in okay someone in my chat just
said can we start playing
it's past their bedtime sounds good good
luck good luck good luck eric good luck
good luck bye yeah i don't think i've
done a match like this before
where there's commentators that i'm part
of a call with
but i'm also commentating so
hopefully it's just a good viewing
experience for for everyone
i encourage people to switch between the
streams watch levy's commentary watch
anna
and hikara's commentary um you'll kind
of hear
you'll hear multiple different
perspectives oh he sent me a challenge
oh he sent me a challenge okay my bad
i thought he was just going to start a
game what's the format
alexa set a timer for 45 minutes
45 minutes starting now okay
i think we're good i'm just gonna make
obs really small so i can't really see
levy
and now we're going to whoa are we going
to stafford
we might first game a staffordshire
okay okay so he's playing the bowden
kizzaritsky
he's gonna play knight c3 i saw he
played this recently
the best moves to take but this is a
funny move
so i can transpose into a center fork
trick so it takes i play d5 oh this is a
move too
um
i think i know the best approach is to
take and play
f6 so i think i'll do that
um i haven't looked at this specifically
in a long time
take down team hikaru thank you merci
i was in the mute alerts um that'll be
the the final
words so now i'm fully focused i might
even take out my headphones too
okay um
let's focus here so bishop i mean
there's bishop c5 and
um in g6 but i'm not sure if i can
get away with that so quickly
and d6 immediately looks to be the
safest
and the combination i have to wear my
headphones to hear the move sounds
weird not hearing anything um
so d6 uh the ideal setup is queen e7 g6
bishop g7 bishop e6
etc he's probably going to throw like f4
at me yeah
that's one of the things you have to
deal with when you play this line
pretty sure queen e7 f5 queen g7
there's also a trap if takes takes i'll
be threatening queen c5 winning the
bishop
so this is a difficult idea to find if
you haven't seen
this line before but this is a kind of
the last thing i remember
i'm not sure if i studied this specific
position that i've studied
related lines
probably bishop d7 i mean light's going
to try and build up like
long-term compensation has more activity
my setup's a bit awkward but
like i'm really solid here keep
everything defended might end up casting
queenside
um it's very important to keep the time
advantage too
i know levi is very very strong in the
time scramble situations
so i imagine he's gonna like be super
aggressive like push the pawns and
um probably what i want to do is focus
on some center play
like after castling i think it's okay
casting bishop d5
it's risky though i might play bishop e7
first and maybe castle kingside
just staying flexible
so b5 i do have the option of that never
mind
i'm not a g5 because now there's no
queen h5 check
i can't castle king side there's a
bishop on c4
i think this is okay like b5 knight a5
bishop d5 i
kind of just chill
so maybe g4 here
not sure how much that accomplishes
i should have kept my bishop back
i play king b8
take a moment here
of this idea bishop e8 doesn't look so
right
let's start with this maybe g3
i'm trying to create some distraction
on g3 h3
that's getting weird it's getting really
weird
this will be a fun first game um
rook e8
or maybe bishop affects
roca f8
yeah it's awkward i'm gonna do weird
things
a5 is probably coming
i'm getting a little bit squeezed
actually
not super pleasant
okay so i want to play d5 if queenside
is a bit in shambles here
it's still i mean it's still really
weird
um because i'm i'm gonna get the center
it's just my king
lack of safety
queen c4 is probably a good move
can i run king d7
there's also a6
i promise bishop e3 is coming man this
is not good
okay not the happiest move there might
be this move but
i just gotta try and survive
so now i'm attacking the bishop if
bishop here king yeah i'll be
threatening d5
it's still alive
i'm trying to employ the cockroach
strategy where
you just keep surviving
even though it looks like you're getting
smooshed
wow
okay this is terrifying
i'm taking is bad
what do i do here
this is really bad i feel so
claustrophobic
stop hurting me
i have no time to
wow that was a good game by him and okay
rematch
i'll play knight f3 let's try and play
um a little bit more solid he plays b6
let's play london
or let's play um what do we call this
queen's indian
queen's indian london hybrid it's
actually kind of an interesting line
yeah knight fd2 is weird but um the idea
is to preserve knight c3
okay so that was the first game um i
mean he played well he's in good form
actually i like the opening there but um
okay can't uh can't live in the past
just have to focus on the future
um i'm liking the opening in this game
because he's clearly out of his prep
um there's some lines i'm prepared in um
i mean the
most natural moves and i hear he's being
a bit
uh exotic knight c6
i assume he wants to play this in this
i'll probably just develop um
yeah playing bishop g3 of e5 i i can
push
i'll probably at some point include e4 i
give g6i
i just want to discourage f5
at pleasant position by h4 here
and one of the plans in this position is
to go
for the eventual uh pawn break on c5
yeah ensuring if a4 i play b4
and now preparing b4
cycling on g6 probably is no good
um he does want to play f5 next move
what i might do is actually put my nylon
e4
idea being here and then here oh but
then
[Music]
it gets weird i'm along f4
i think that line's okay like here here
f4 i take on g6
it should be fine
i'm just trying to make my knight
happier up a minute on the clock too
so this is the type of game i just want
to keep
keep the position rolling knight e6
looks attractive
he wants to play bishop c8
that's interesting
so 96 bishop c8
g7 no good
f3 at some point
um
i could trade too
queenie two is a move
i have a cool idea actually i'm gonna
play queen e2
so the point is after uh takes takes
takes bishop h4 queen h6f3 traps tonight
did someone gift a massive amount of
subs
holy holy holy i have alerts still on
tribe castle that's a ton of subs
it's not ending either thanks for
thanks for that i appreciate the
generosity
um wait this is my calculation here i do
have to still stay focused oh f3 there's
knight takes e3
that's a miscalculation
um
i just lost a pawn and g5 might be
coming
f4 is interesting actually
f4 looks so anti-positional
but i'm i'm securing the square
it's actually it's kind of
nerve-wracking when i know hikaru is
like watching my play and probably
judging
judging moves like this
but at least i have some purpose
a castle yeah my king needs safety
so i'm down the pawn but it's not too
bad because i have the dark square
control
so i can't i'll address alerts later
um i again appreciate the support
um if i take
i'm taking is bad
to play this move
yeah how am i down on time i was up a
minute earlier
uh there's probably massive problems in
this position with takes in queen d4
[Music]
but then maybe i survive
this bishop f42
oh let's take
it looks really really ugly but at least
i have rook d1
and his bishop is um i always have to
look on the right side this bishop's
kind of a
a sad piece but my whole king side is
really sad
he's so active and this this position's
in levy's wheelhouse too he loves like
having initiative being aggressive but
we're gonna
try and employ the cockroach strategy
hear this move
have a small time advantage
there is some prospect if i can trade
the lights for bishop for the knight
it would be obstacle bishops
so that's kind of what i'm going for
to play this move sadly
a4 was scary
oh no okay this is maybe survivable
he's gonna take with f pawn and play g3
f5 here
debating i'll play rook b2
i want to play this and attack the pawn
maybe
i can't play that am i just losing oh no
i'm just losing there's no moves to stop
bishop d3
any stale matrix
no i'm losing good game actually i'll
let him i'll play it out for the
beginners who don't understand okay good
game levy
okay um rough start
but it's it's a gambit i guess
to lose a few games to
maybe give him a false sense of
confidence play b5 here
funny move
okay how much time is left 25 minutes
left
so again not the end of the world
um i'm gonna try and stay focused mount
some kind of comeback
yeah so if knight bd7 there's knight c6
i'll probably play c5 here
realizing he could potentially take on
d5
c5 takes on d5
we trade oh there is a funny move
actually
so if he takes takes takes i have knight
b6
otherwise my rook would be i'd lose
material but knight b6 would defend the
rook and
attack the bishop and bishop moves back
out of knight d5
okay so
at least i saw some tactic there
uh hopefully i'm not missing any like
strong follow-up but the
yeah if pawn takes takes there's no b7
because my bishop defends
and now i have knight d5 he has knight
f4
um so it's still kind of messy
but i am temporarily up a piece which is
nice
also up on time
so probably knight c6
it's weird the bishop is shish kebabbing
my pieces
but things are defended
or are they
there's a funny line here 94.
which i might end up doing
man it's so hard to calculate knight d4
queen d592
we trade i think it's okay i
get like two pieces for a rook in the
end
so the point is i take on e2 with check
i win the night i lose a rook we trade
queens
and in the end i have bishop and knight
for rook and two pawns but this pawn
would be weak and i
have an attack on the the work on f1 i
also have knight g3 and bishop f1 in the
end
i think
okay that's a good sign
so probably roxy8
rook b8 york b8
time is about level i mean i'm up a
piece i have good activity
and pieces are actually really nicely
like centralized and
the only concern is my knights are our
targets
but they're also weapons
yeah i like the rook on b8
anytime maybe i can simplify
um there's knight b3 here
actually takes uh takes on d3
and if queen takes i have knight b4
knight c2
if pawn takes i just take on c5 i'm up a
clean piece
a lot of shish kebab going on this game
so probably knight dc2 preventing rook
d1
forking the rooks i'm already up a piece
i'm about to
oh that's a tricky move
it's not so simple
i think rook c8 is a move to play rook c
rook d1 rook takes c5
it kind of complicates things but i
think it just simplifies
just making sure
yeah everything's defended here and both
queens are hanging
but if we trade queens then we probably
end up trading rooks this rook still
attacked
queen has very few squares queen b3 i
take and hit the queen
queen e4 i mean i could take the rook
but yeah i don't want to complicate
things
more than i need to queen e8
it's rook d5 no
d5 we trade
it is weird queen eight
not the move i wanted to play
offer trade
oh no take some bishop d6 then rook
uh cc8
oh that moved first
so rook c8
okay it's gonna be a fight
so i have two minors for rook and two
pawns
b2 is tender knights are weird but they
defend each other
rook e8 is a
potential move
it takes on b2
[Music]
i don't think i want to do that yet play
g6
trying defendings
good position now i think
oh no
gotta go for it right now
no
no
[Music]
oh no my
my time oh that was so sad
oh i feel so broken man that should have
been an easy win too
okay um let's stay calm
let's stay calm
i mean kudos to him for being fast and
tricky with a rook
that's so sad
okay i have to treat every loss as a
gambit i got
yeah i got forked and then i got too
complacent
at least we have okay we have another
opening i'm comfy with
so it's so important like in these
situations that you don't
you don't tilt you stay focused you
forget the past suppress the past
i think he plays this as white so he's
trying to figure out like what to do is
black
that's a move
i just want to be solid just stop the
bleeding
some idea knight g310 to h5
is kind of interesting
this is going to be a long match too um
because we're starting out with slower
games but then we get into the quicker
games so
[Music]
we'll probably play at least like 20
games total
this could be the or no we're gonna have
one more game after this
there's 13 minutes left and this game
can go max seven minutes
okay probably this move i do not h5
there's also some idea knight f5 which
is
a bit fancier um takes takes and then
not sure how to evaluate that
castling
okay so let's just put the knight here i
might end up playing e5 at some point
i take the bishop
maybe a4
a4 b4
let's be solid
i should have probably taken the bishop
actually just not to give him the option
of
bishop h8 oh but no
i could play d5
leave the tension too
go for this idea
yeah i think i want to take the bishop
just so when the position opens up later
i'll have the bishop hair
and now the other knight's coming into
the
the holes in box position up so much
time let's try and keep the pace
and there's g4 ideas
we trade
so i might end up taking or playing that
if i first a few approaches
d5 is also a move
yeah i think i i wanna go in first
so king h2 is actually interesting to
prepare g3
so if d5 g3 drops a knight
oh no it doesn't because not h5
but g3 is still an idea just to chase
away the knight
f3 is interesting
f3 e3 queen d3
rookie eight
maybe queen e2 first hitting
um hitting this pawn and this pawn
maybe preparing f3
and actually this pawn is valuable
because if i can take on b5 i'll have c4
okay so he wants to play rook e8
this is okay though
i'll have f3
so a3 i play b3
trying to play quick and solid
maybe i'll just move back
let's move prophylaxis
i want to play c4 soon
um yeah c4
could trade rooks
don't like it too long time to want to
blunder
d5
d5 is kind of cool just opening up the
bishop
f6
how to do this maybe queen g4 first
now i have six and i play bishop c3
and probably take and take
as knights are completely restricted
oh we trade e3 hangs eventually
and king here here doesn't work because
g4 with a fork if knight g7 then g4
expecting e4
and then i probably take or okay i take
anyway
go for h4 now
i just don't want a mouse slip like that
um i'll escape i just blundered but uh
okay we're gonna hide oh
play this move
plenty of time
okay we have time yeah we have time for
one more game i think
in this section okay it's playing b3
i'll play this line again
so um
let's play i'll play knight g7 and just
e6 and i'll play reverse toy
hey my first win let's celebrate i'm not
getting adopted
um that's some accomplishment right
it's important to i guess set the bar
low at first and then gradually set the
bar higher and higher
now the goal is to win another game
um there's no need to
actually maybe there is some need takes
play this some idea queen b8 eventually
so i'm just preventing the knight from
coming in
okay
i don't think lovey usually plays these
structures but i mean this is very solid
for
for both sides i kind of want to play b5
here
i was thinking bishop here but then we
just trade bishop d3
yeah one plan is to expand and then have
the queen
rook and maybe even other work on the
queen side
very positional game just going for
going for kind of the small battles
rather than the
vicious attack
another idea is rookie at e5 but i don't
think i want to bust open the center too
soon
that's a respectable move
oh there's a funny line so this move
bishop d3 then i take
and if takes i uh take and then win the
bishop
um so the one of the calculations is
oh actually even better just to take
first and then take here i think
and then win a clean pawn
if here then there's queen trap so the
other calculation was takes and then
takes i think just
trades i mean there's takes in the takes
on h7
[Music]
yeah let's take here first
so yeah the queen is useful because now
the the pawns pinned
wait what
does that work that might work actually
my queen get trapped
wait no i have queen a3
23 c5 or queen b2 c5
i think i i have to play it and then
c5 worst case scenario i win the pawn
um e5 is interesting
yeah so i could go back and maybe
slightly better there
i would like to find a way to hold on to
the piece
um which might involve making things
really messy
it might not even work too
yeah rook b1
probably better off saving time
okay queen b8
so i'll be up upon
i'll have a weak backwards c6 pawn but
um
there's some chances i'll get to play c5
i think he's considering this move
okay
down a little bit of time but position
is
now pretty easier to play i could play
c5 right away actually
the problem is queen a3
hey queen e3 is tricky i play e5
too
[Music]
i shouldn't be taking time here i might
just uh double up and chill
it's kind of passive but it's solid
again c5 there's queen a3
okay so now the pawn is pinned along the
rink
oh alexa quiet
um there's might be a here
it looks really passive i want to bring
the other knight back so i can play c5
yeah c5 now there's still queen a3 but
then queen b6
because i have uh i have so many
defenders
four defenders
can dig with rook or knight
probably night
[Music]
it's actually trickier than i originally
thought maybe queen f8
has a safer option
queen b6 rook b2
queen a6 maybe it's okay
i can maybe develop
it's very tricky position it's hard to
internalize everything
but things are defended for now
queen a6 is probably a move i want to
play i also want to make loot for my
king at some point
let's play 97 can i just take that takes
take six
okay time is the biggest concern
okay i'm gonna get the knight to c4 and
then things will be comfy
i lost the pawn da my pawn
please take it add that crankmate there
uh knight c3
rook c3
no my queen
no
ah ah such a nice game too
i'll go for the mating attack
okay i resigned ah okay
i feel like i've i had good positions um
and especially the last game but
i guess it wasn't meant to be oh such a
nice position
it's just too slow um
yeah i was too hesitant in time trouble
too just had to play
quicker moves unfortunately
i can't easily break through here
oh levi sent a challenge okay
um okay let's start
i'm gonna mute alerts again and
wait what's the format
alexa set alarm for 25 minutes
25 minutes starting now
oh alexa cancel the alarm
your alarm is not set oh alexa cancel
the timer
25 minute timer cancelled alexa
timer for 30 minutes
30 minutes okay
okay so this segment is 30 minutes um
got confused there for a moment
so i'm playing e3 this is actually a
move i prepared a long time ago
um for an opponent that didn't go into
it the point is to play the early bishop
b5 c4 etc and if black plays e6 and the
bishop gets disconnected and i'll have a
lot of
pressure on the queen side
yeah so if a6 i take queen a495
this is um old preparation which i'm
fond of
uh probably just knight c3 here
imagine he'll play 97
yeah maybe still queen a4
could end up trading a bit actually the
the both bishops can take double my
pawns and then we'll have two bishops
first two nights
oh he's letting me take here now let's
take here first
okay so time is so important um because
we're playing three minutes
and it is hard to adjust
i assume i'll take oh it doesn't take
you see five
just to return
yeah that's a move it's actually kind of
an
annoying
move i have a3
it's going to be really weird pawn
structure or maybe okay maybe it's not
too weird
i don't mind this
g1 might end up stacking h2
bishop there's a b2 it's kind of weird
but
um on the castle queen side
have to take actually play rook
[Music]
now
um not pleased with the position
maybe it takes an f4
now this might be uncomfortable
f5 is interesting
a good move probably should take first
turning into bullet now
i don't care about c3
let's go okay i saw that coming too wow
let's go oh what a game okay
let's go i got him got him
okay um i just realized we don't see
levy's expression
uh let's go
give me one moment here i have to put
studio mode
and play e6 here
i'll just take a moment
no there we go okay
um
i think we're good
what do i play here play bishop
d6
i remember actually preparing this uh
specifically for levy
where he plays some like queen c2 and
then
i think it's e5 immediately
some like shanklin wesley sew game
i'm not sure though maybe it's 97 first
i think i wait for rook g1 or g4 and
then i play e5
i'm forgetting my prep though
[Music]
let's just hope this is right so g5 uh
d4 i think
and it's been so long since i've looked
at this
i don't think this is my prep but looks
interesting
i'll probably take with knight
steal some idea e4
do this move idea to
bring the bishop to a safe place
okay
try and stay focused
yeah he wants to attack me
um bishop b4 is interesting
this bishop is better than this bishop
i might uh might eventually go further
the a pawn push
okay so he's stacking upon to open some
lines
i guess there's uh takes in queen
[Music]
queen f5 g6 we sacks
i think it's okay so linus takes takes
queen f5 g6
takes takes takes and queen g7
oh he can just take here though oops
um so it might be hard to defend things
i might uh might play rook t8
instead
oh there's a funny line so rook d8 if we
trade and he takes
i play queen here king b1 rook d2 and
it's winning
because he has no except we have
perpetual
he sacks and plays queen g5
because at some point i play queen f8
i guess we're not going into that
because um
as rook is staying on i have g6 so
we might just get some equal end game
trade
i have to figure out what to do here
in this move
so rig h1 there's always g6 we might end
up trading first
initiative is more important than
material
b5 coming
let's go okay oh i was winning the queen
okay let's go meet you down
okay so i actually i prepared a little
bit of this beforehand just to transpose
into london
i prepared like the his main london line
um so we're finally getting on london
the e3 here
oh he's playing it'll be tricky i'll
leave the bishop here
i know komski's been playing this um a
little bit
ooh so if i take
i'm taking is actually a a reasonable
way of playing
it just leads to a pleasant structure
even though he doubles my pawns gets the
bishop here
um oh i guess he has a choice there yeah
[Music]
okay i'm kind of on my own now actually
um this may have been a bad opening for
me
bishop e2
i'll play bishop b5 maybe queen e2
oh he doesn't have the bishop hair got
confused there
yeah this position resembles like a
reverse queen's gambit accepted
if knight b takes maybe c6 but maybe not
but maybe
okay preventing e5 at some point i'll
probably play a3
g3
i'm just trying to build my formation
trying to get the ideal setup so a3 rook
d1 knight d4
um yeah i can't really stop e5
but there's squirts to work with i mean
b5 square
time is reasonable
go for maybe trading off one pair of
knights or maybe not
in this move
now rooks belong on slightly different
ranks
um i move back threatening b4 now
yeah this is a way more positional
strategic game
it could be a long end game grind
solid position probably each for maybe
h5 at some point
cure pressure the pawn
queen g6
there's a funny line
oh maybe maybe it's not so funny
let's play this i gotta move quicker
so knight will come on to b4
this pawn's weak i might be winning a
pawn actually
yeah i'm winning a pawn
here's some counter play attack the
knight
there's some small threat i don't think
it's so bad though because king g2
rook f3 rook t2
he wins back a couple pawns
uh free rook
okay that was nice yeah he didn't uh
didn't find the right line there
um okay let's go hey come back time
um at some point i might play cecilia if
he
plays more e4 oh we have a scotch
what does he play here
is he take or bishop c4 i don't know
what he plays
he can play sin would be funny
okay so this is prep i might play e5
here
oh we're going into yeah this is my main
danish prep
so the point after knight c3 to take and
play queen c4
yeah this is kind of surprising because
he usually doesn't play
this sort of thing bishop e2 i think i i
win a pawn maybe even two pawns
i'm winning two pawns actually
it's still tricky because white will
have the wait what
so it's playable but we'll have the
bishop hair
there's a funny variation where i castle
fork
i don't think it's wait what
why didn't he take back oh he wants to
play
queen b7 but i have bishop b4
i'm gonna be up at peace oh he's trying
to make things weird
um let me move bishop e1
[Music]
so bishop b4a3
trying to navigate through the chaos
here
um
not sure what to do after e3 and it's
good for black
every line i'm just of material
yeah so probably now queen f6
a3 and then
[Music]
like bishop bishop a5
this looks okay bishop a5 defending c7
so after he takes rook
b8 queen a6
bishop b6 bishop b5 97 so i have enough
defenders i'll have time to castle
that should be okay
and but by okay i mean completely
winning
but never know can't get too relaxed
and if he doesn't take i play bishop b6
and it's it's very solid
g4
g5 incoming
so there's nine minutes left of the this
portion
g5 queen f5
probably just castle here
go for this move
um i have three
and f3 seals a deal
there's actually a weird line when he
wins off seven
i don't think it matters though because
i take and i'm not getting mated
it's almost tricky
um
queen just queen b5
it looks kind of risky like back ring my
queen attacked but
bishop's pinned i'm just meeting
probably
or winning on time or both
well that's why you always got to stay
focused like be be blunder checking
especially if you have enough time
okay that was nice so probably time for
two more games here
i've been liking another three because
we potentially got london
or um oh if he repeats the same line i
might deviate
but he usually mixes it up oh he's
playing g6
um so with this
i remember studying this actually um
i'm going to use a similar idea to one
of the previous games of queen b1
and then b4 it's unusual but at least
it's a plan
and sometimes the issue with the
structure is like black completes
development then it's not clear
oh maybe it is clear what black wants to
do
um so one of the points of b4
is to drive the knight away so it's
harder for black to play e5
i'm also yeah again the same theme of
alignment with the undefended bishop so
he closes things down
um
yeah i might might start with this and
see where the night goes
maybe this idea
general the bishop's not good against
the structure but one of the points is
to eventually play e4
so again more strategic game
also we're tied i shouldn't focus on the
score though should just
focus on the position at hand
e5 might come
no e5 is covered i have three three
attackers there's only two supporters
i mean 95 is always a consideration
like the two kind of moves to make
progress
are eventually e4 or knight e5 f4
very typical when you have the structure
i'm just going to play a nothing move
because rook creates a nothing move so
i can do nothing too but this is like
just long term
i'm going to play four eventually
probably rookie one
yeah 95 and then decide how to
move the pawns and that's seven is very
tempting here
probably not called four but maybe
called for
we trade
i have time i don't want to make things
too weird i probably just move here this
knight's complete out of play
okay
queen before queen e7
i mean maybe now um now e4
okay making progress there is a square
on b3 but
d1 the knight's not doing much looks
pretty
basically a decoration
nice ornament okay so i want to play
queen b7 maybe knight c6
knight g4
and a lot of fun moves here let's start
with knight c6
yeah this is more than just a decoration
this is a weapon
of bishop e5 almost dropping the queen
oh there's a funny line look at this
line queen f5 97 with a fork
discovery fossil okay
i've kind of feel good game so far
threatening bishop d6 actually if takes
i'd probably take with pawn
because then rook to e8 is hard to stop
king g7 rook d8 never mind
okay so now this
this move pressuring both pawns
we can see two i take on c4 or take on
f8 and take on e6
looks more solid
return
oh let's not plunder a rook play this
[Music]
move
okay plenty of time
okay that was a really feel good game
okay first time having the lead in the
match
there's one minute left of the segment
so this will be the final game of 3-0
is he going to play at london too oh he
plays a dumb toy
i shared this on stream the other day i
prepared this a year ago
for ben feingold um
h4 is a funny move so the point is just
to
do things on the queen side um
that's playable that's actually maybe
the best way to justify this line
take first okay we're going to get some
weird position
um
yeah it's annoying i couldn't play e6 so
have to chase the bishop back
and then e6
oh he's being feisty
i might have to take knight takes we
trade
alexa stop it
um
and takes
not i shouldn't take so much time here
let's just do it and
hope for the best like we trade a lot
knight d2 f5
i mean if i win a pawn and we trade
queens it's not a bad thing
i lose casting rights you might be
considering taking bishop b5 but
it should be okay oh there's queens like
oh there's that move too
okay i might be getting punished here
to move back
yeah this is actually turning really bad
king seven maybe
bong cloud okay at least i'm playing
like hikaru
what um i do here a6
and then cry
i mean b5 expand
preventing knight c4
maybe rook g8
because i want to play this or maybe
this works just better on g8 i have
nothing developed except my king
um 97
i've got to move faster oh i'd allow
knight c6 but then king f6 will develop
the king
king will get some exercise
okay i still might want to play g5 at
some point
uh maybe this move
i just want to trade everything and be
up a pawn
wow
okay so g5 take some rook takes
king g7 f5 is some some setup
oh let's not blunder play this first
i'm scared
i don't know what a5 is but it's a move
legal moves are good
sometimes
i'm getting forks
ah yeah i got flagged good game well
played
wow we're tied how are we tied okay
well it comes down to the bullet portion
wow
only game okay alexa set a timer for 30
minutes
30 minutes starting now okay turning off
alerts and good luck and i'm going to
repeat the same opening
okay we're going to play mainline this
time
97 is a bit strange
oh no
[Music]
might be able to get away with this
it's not pleasant
ah that was a crazy time scramble
okay i'm just a bit slower
um okay that's not a bad game though
tried to fight i play queen d6 this time
i was already bad position maybe b5
b5 is interesting knight's kind of stuck
this move
this move
this move i don't know
wait what no
oh this might be rough
never give up
i need to resign okay i resign okay
okay not the end of the world uh i'll
play e4
okay french
yeah this is not the greatest french
exchange
because i forgot all my prep
but it's something
it's actually really ugly though yeah
i'm alive
i hung a knight or he hung a knife but i
didn't take it
no that was such a bad move oh no
ah he knew what to do oh he knew my trap
oh uh i trapped shakaro with that once
it was fun okay
okay let's play f6
it was actually a funny line
yeah i'm acting like a carl again
[Music]
it feels wrong but it kind of feels fun
i mean there's king takes what would
recaro do
uh am i losing
oh i think i'm alive
kind of i'm up at peace
it's not that bad i don't think
okay king got some exercise
uh
i don't know what my plan is though
develop weirdly
oh no
oh what a weird game that was such a sad
game i tried to play like hikaru it
didn't work okay let's play um
play knives three again
i prepared this actually i think
yeah i played hikaru in this line
recently
so knight b1 is still um i mean it was a
prepared idea
i might have to go back though
okay
like we need three
this is just not working it's not
working for me
okay we'll get this position
only down the pawn
now two pawns
wow that was mate that was meat oh i
thought it was almost coming back too
okay only five down
and levy's actually really strong in 1-0
okay playing a london against a london
um oh this is just reverse queen's
gambit accepted
in pleasant position but it's not always
enough
should consider bishop e4 ideas
queen b7 ideas
king side's a bit naked
up a lot of time though
okay let's not get adopted in the bullet
let's go
no adoption for you
i feel like the soup guy from seinfeld
don't make me queen h8 with sneaky mate
let's go okay i feel so accomplished can
i retire now
play e4 again oh let's play an ortho
shop
okay he's scared of the ortho schnapp
um
okay this is gonna be very close
maneuvering game
tricky
yeah i just have to play quick in the
opening so i don't get low on time later
easier said than done
c5 d6 is a an interesting plan
good move
i'm worse i lost a bishop
he's a long time no
my queen
ooh it's a fork
no my knight
stop hurting me oh
okay um
ac5
can't remember the theory here some
weird theory
play natural moves
oops i was a mouse slip but okay
i didn't mean to pre-move that
some d5 is weak
this is kind of terrifying
that was a terrible move
somehow i'm surviving though
nice puzzle rush
i'm gonna win on time
oh i went on time how'd that happen i
don't know how that happened but i
wanted time let's go so there's 13
minutes left
i need a streak starting now
guy hung upon he doesn't take it
some lag
probably want to play a5 he beats me to
it
so bring the knight to b3
again up on time
calvin d6 hopefully or b6
what is this no
ah i got mated okay
11 minutes let's play stafford ah
okay we're going into this
um supposed to take
i forget
he tricked me he may have tricked me
i have to play like a karo again bong
cloud time
oh no
my queen
that's so sad
why do i keep playing like hikaru like
usually when he develops his king he
wins
it's not fair
okay um i'm down on time
i have an active rook i'm losing my
active rook
but i have the bishop here i'm losing my
bishop pair too
it's so sad
everything's pinned i resign okay
that's a really bad game that was good
game on his part though
um play this line
wow tricky
and there's so much lag
but i can't make excuses i'm just
getting out played so many of these
games
um let's play play this move
okay let's positional sack
um
[Music]
okay let's go for the push
g5 queen c7
it's interesting each six ideas never
mind
okay so e6 is a target
close to equal time add this move to
tricky move
no i wasn't expecting queen of eight
ah i have a good position too
enough time there's no reason to
pre-move queen h6
okay we move on
i don't know if it's mathematically
possible to come back but
you never know
except you might know
oh he's playing um
[Music]
very aggressively look at this move
yeah this should be fine for black i
think
king will go to h8 bishop to e6
don't make me i don't think i'm getting
mated
things are defended
time advantage
bishop defended each one
oh are you serious life's not fair
okay
i really don't like these time scrambles
oh it's meeting wow how am i meeting he
got opposition which is not the best
strategy when you're on the back rank
okay that's funny unexpected help mate
uh let's play one of these
yeah there's no time to come back
unfortunately
but we'll try and finish strong
oh no just as i say that i have to play
queen g1
i'm still alive though wait what
a fascinating move okay we'll simplify
i don't think he's going to take the
rook it's not his style
nope never mind
okay let's win this game
let's go okay i won the game i can still
farm him for raiding actually
these last few games please just go for
a stafford
okay no stafford
play let's move yeah we're going into
some main line
i'll play d4
very ugly position for white
no offense to levy's position
so i want to play this move take some
knight b3
two minutes left
almost mother mating queen a1 first
i want to play d3 i always play f6
i should not have played f6
d3
oh no
draw okay draw that was a weird game
i'll play knight three again
okay we're we're playing in the style of
magna sakaru
is this
can i sac mate
my kings why is my king on e3
uh takes
a check
what is this position
it's all about controlling the center
sometimes with your king
don't hurt me
don't hurt me you know you want to but
you
don't want to
okay my king's getting a lot of exercise
alexa stop it
alexa make me feel better about myself
singing can help lift the spirits wait i
don't like to sing
my best to cheer you up can you alexa
sing a copyright free song
copyright free by fantastic no
not the song copy oh no i'm getting
mated oh no
alexa quiet
oh okay good game at least i got
no never mind levi played well
good job to levy um yeah he completely
overpowered me in the bullet even though
i did win some games
i stayed over 2700
alexa stop hurting me
is eric here i'm i think i'm here you i
joined the audio you guys can hear me
right
hey eric hey levy good games and you
overpowered me in the the bullets
had too many games where we were at
least where i developed my king too
early
i honestly it was it it was it was all a
blur i was getting very frustrated
in the bullet games i was just like i
don't know what happened
it's like uh but it's like the story of
all of our matches they're like
what lopsided one way and then like we
we make it even um
it's like very streaky yeah yeah some of
those
i guess uh the early games i i liked my
openings but you were getting better at
me and the
time scrambles and then um but they were
they were fun games like
i always enjoy playing you eric question
sure why do you always play one move
against me is it because you know i'm
gonna self-destruct
well this today i mix things up
more than i usually do
but what what are you referring to like
you played knight f3 every game in blitz
i was like begging
like waiting for e4 d4 c4 but well i
kept playing it because you kept
changing yeah changing your response so
originally if you kept playing the same
thing i was going to mix things up but
you you were the one mixing things up
and
um i was waiting for you to play f5 but
you never did
i know i know you were waiting for me to
play a fight yeah i had some fun
dutch lines for perry are you gonna play
d3 or e4
i was gonna play d so knight f3 f5 d3 i
saw you play knight c6
and then i was going to play d4 which is
like the top engine move
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah don't tell them
that eric come on oh
i guess i mean he's telling the secrets
well i mean it's it's his prerogative he
wants to i guess
all right no no no no people are going
to know um exactly what the best moves
are right
how did you kind of i was curious i mean
at the start for you eric obviously
it was a very rough start in the first
three games that that cell mate in the
middle kind of
sort of changed the tone i was just
wondering if like you felt more
confident after that or what exactly was
going through your mind at that point in
time
yeah i mean honestly even after the
first few games
i think i was down like 3-0 or 4-1
i wasn't feeling so bad about my play
like i was getting reasonable positions
in the opening and then
um i guess one of my biggest weaknesses
is converting
good positions or just letting like a
good advantage slip
and some of it is i think is due to time
management um
i think this is where hikaru you really
excel like when you get a good position
you just keep playing quickly you keep
the tempo which unfortunately i wasn't
able to do
in some of these earlier games i mean
you just gotta master the tempo that's
that's all it's about
i've heard that's kind of the secret to
getting good really quickly
but these matches are always fun i don't
know about you eric but like when people
ask me if
we analyze the games of these matches i
maybe will go and review an opening line
but basically
not at all well i'm really looking
forward to like going back
listening to your thoughts and hikaru
and anna's commentary um i can't
remember last time
actually so the last time hicaro
commentated on my games
i think maybe was a little bit during
like the speedchest championship matches
but then before that um hikaru you
actually commentated
over the board game i played about 10
years ago i don't
don't know if you remember there's no
way that i'm gonna remember that right
off
um i i was trying to find the the
lewis it was a st louis jr closed in
2010
oh wow and you you made a guest
appearance for a few rounds i think you
were commentating with jen jahadi
um i was back when it was streamed on
livestream.com
like before the days of twitch
i was literally no recollection of that
at all okay it was one of like the
highlights of my life
because yeah i used to illustrated
players and
i was playing ray rotson in the first
round and i drew him and
then you interviewed me after the game
so
but you have no proof that i don't have
perfect memory because i literally have
no recollection of that whatsoever
wow not in the game what were you doing
in 2010
it doesn't then i think i played the
chess olympia that year
wow what a memory eric
that's amazing well i remember it
specifically
because hikaru like during the during
the commentary said
in 10 years from now eric will look back
on this and say it's like such a cool
experience
um and that's why i was i thought about
the other day i was trying to find the
vod but it's it's
not on youtube and i'll have to wow
yeah it's probably somewhere in the st
louis they have it right yeah i
literally have no recollection
you guys know the prize by the way
hikaru he kind of decided there was a
prize for this match
uh sadly the chat did spoil that yes
i was not aware there was a prize yeah
uh yeah i was gonna say the winner is
gonna get like a basket of lemons or
lemon-based products so i'm gonna have
to go
find something for for uh for levy on
the
lemons that sounds um
you know uh yeah actually
i don't know how i don't know do we can
i tell you i'm gonna tell you that guys
something gross uh alex
my friend alex uh he likes to eat lemons
he puts sugar on lemons and he likes to
eat them
that's not gross i like that too as a
kid i used to eat that
slices of lemon with sugar on it is
really good it's healthy and also it's
like a candy with sugar
it's high in vitamin c yeah some people
are into like sour things
yeah it's not gross no you're right
you're right it's um it's interesting uh
it's def
it's definitely let's put it this way
it's one of these things where like if
your friend does it you're like well
that's disgusting like
because he's you know he's your friend
so you want to but anna that's no that's
great
um that's awesome you're keeping a good
vitamin count
you know staying healthy i actually i
did go through a phase where i just ate
lemons um
because there's called there's these
things called miracle berries
they're like these exotic berries grown
i think in south america
and you'll you'll have like they're in
tablet form you take one
and it changes your taste buds so it
makes anything sour taste really sweet
so after you have a miracle berry you
eat a lemon and it tastes like like
candy
and uh you can get them online like
they're
they're pretty cheap they make fun gifts
so
wow never heard of this wow it's uh
yeah maybe something to add to the gift
basket of lemons
does that does that i mean
not not to join in on the party but like
or or
ruin it for lefty but i too have also
eaten lemons not with salt but i like i
love
salt we're sorry sorry
sugar okay okay yes lemon salt relates
to something uh
quite different shall we say